الينا من عمان مهند هادي منسقه الامم
المتحده الاقليمي للشؤون الانسانيه في
سوريا
سيد هذه هل هناك وعود قطعت ولم تنفذ فيما
يتعلق بالمساعدات الانسانيه
مساء الجمال وشكرا على استضافته على قناه
الجزيره
بالنسبه للمساعدات الانسانيه طبعا وكما
ورد في تقريركم احنا بدانا من اول ما
اتاحت لنا الفرصه انه نوصل مساعدات قد
بدانا كانت طبعا في البدايه الطريق الى
الحدود مغلقه من خلال تركيا مغلقه واول ما
فتحت الطريق وتيح لنا اول يوم دخلنا ست
شاحنات بعدين 14 شاحنه واليوم فوتنا 22
شاحنه واحنا في صدد زياده هذا العدد حتى
نوفي بالتزاماتنا ونقدم الاحتياجات لجميع
الناس
ولا نزال نعمل مع جميع الاطراف للسماح لنا
بالوصول الى المصابين في شمال غرب سوريا
وفي الحقيقه في كل سوريا من جميع الاطراف
وبكافه الطرق المتاحه الينا ولكن الامم
المتحده طالبت في عدم تسييس المساعدات هل
هناك استجابه لهذا الطلب هل هناك من اليه
مثلا مبتكره تتجاوز
ربما القيود الحاليه ناحيه ظرفيه فقط
لاسباب ظرفيه
كلامك سليم مئه بالمئه وهذا اللي احنا
بنعمله دائما في مجال العمل الانساني نطلب
دائما عدم تسييس العمل الانساني وخصوصا في
هذه الظروف الاستثنائيه اللي عم بتمر فيها
السوريه بل المنطقه كلها احنا نطلب من
الجميع ووضع سلامه الناس قبل كل شيء قبل
اي اعتبارات سياسيه ولهذا السبب الامم
المتحده عم نطالب من اعضاء مجلس الامن
بالسماح لنا بدخول من معابر اخرى من من عن
طريق تركيا غير باب الهوى باب السلامه
وايضا منافذ منافذ اخرى ثانيه نتواصل مع
مع الاطراف مع الدول بخصوص موضوع
بخصوص موضوع التوصيل حتى من خلال من خلال
سوريا بخصوص القيود اللي موضوعها على
سوريا
نتواصل مع جميع الاطراف لحل كافه الامور
الاداريه اي شيء يعيق وصولنا الى الناس
نحاول
هاي الصعاب حل هذه المشاكل حتى لا نتاخر
نحن في معركه مع الزمن الان
اي ساعه نخسرها ممكن نخسر فيها ارواح لهذا
السبب جميع منظمات الامم المتحده تعمل في
نفس الوقت للوصول الى الناس ولكن ربما
يكون الوضع في سوريا مختلف الناس الان في
الشوارع هم بحاجه الى ماوى هل ترى بان
الاولويه الان يجب ان تكون خاصه
للسوريين بسبب الظروف التي كانوا يعيشونها
قبل الزلزال وما بعد الزلزال
طبعا هو مما لا شك فيه انه الظروف اللي
كانت قبل الزلزال هو ظروف قاسيه ومن حضرتك
تفضلت وحكيت في بدايه النشره انه السوريين
يعانوا من ويلات الحرب منذ سنوات والان
بعض في خلال والان ما بعد نتائج الزلزال
زادت معاناه الشعب الشعب السوري فهم بحاجه
الى ماوى وهم بحاجه الى خيم اليوم دخلت
عبر الشاحنات دخلت بعض الخيم لكنها ليست
كفايه عدد النازحين عدد المشردين اكبر من
هذا العدد من هذا العدد في كثير طبعا
بدايه في بدايه اي زلزال وكوارث انسانيه
كوارث طبيعيه بدايه هي عمليات البحث
والانقاذ بعد هذا بتبدا موضوع
العنايه الصحيه ومن بعد ذلك طبعا بيكون في
الماوى
والمواد الغذائيه وبرنامج الاغذيه
العالميه يقدم مواد غذائيه الا اننا في
الحقيقه برنامج تؤذيه العالمي او شك مخزون
على النفاه ولهذا السبب احنا من طالب
الدول المانحه
المساعدات الفوريه والعاجله حتى لا حتى لا
يتم انقطاع في تقديم في تقديم هذه
المساعدات لكن الاحتياجات هي اكبر من
الامكانيات اللي موجوده عنا عنا عنا اليوم
احنا في خلال 48 ساعه القادمه سوف يعلن
الامين العام ونائب الامين العام عن عن
الاحتياجات الماديه في خلال الثلاث اشهر
القادمه وطبعا كما تفضلت انت سوف عمليه
عمليه ما بعد ما بعد الزلزال سوف تستمر
اشهر اكثر بيضه مهند هادي ما هي الاولويات
بالنسبه
للمناطق المنكوبه في سوريا
الاولويات الاولويات الان طبعا الرعايه
الصحيه تقديم السكن مؤقت ولو عن طريق عن
طريق الخيم
الغذاء وفي الايام القادمه وفي الاسابيع
القادمه سوف نكتشف انه في اولويات سوف
تفرض نفسها من مياه صرف صحي قد تتفشى
امراض نتيجه نتيجه الاوبئه ناهيك عن ناهيك
عن عن الجو وسقوط
الثلج
والظروف الجويه القاسيه اللي بمر فيها
الناس في الحقيقه نحن حتى نتتبع
الانباء الجويه والاخبار الجويه حتى نشوف
ايش النشره ايش النشرات الجويه القادمه في
خلال الايام والاسابيع القادمه حتى نكون
يعني مستعدين لهذه لهذه التغيرات
والتقلبات الجويه مهند هذه منسق الامم
المتحده الاقليميه للشؤون الانسانيه في
سوريا متحدثا من عمان شكرا شكرا جزيلا لك